is the purpose of script analysis
purpose of script analysis is to figure
out what there is to be shot
and that's you know the core of the
scene the the
some people call it the Nugget of the
scene the uh the what it's about the I
like to use this term emotional event
and I tried to find something catchier
but it just expresses what I want to say
so I stick to it
but um
it's to it's to find out what there is
to be shot I was talking to a former
student of mine just a few days ago
who's been directing television well
first she she did a she did a beautiful
beautiful independent feature film that
uh oh just wonderful a couple of years
ago and then from that she started
getting some work doing television
and so we were we were having lunch with
with her and another former student and
and she was saying that she felt still
felt really puzzled about how to figure
out how to do television because
you know it's because there's no time
she had spent a whole year preparing for
her for her uh feature film that her
independent feature film and uh and and
she she was just puzzled like like
because I she said I don't know how to
be sure that I get what I have to get
and I said well you know I think you're
looking at it from the wrong point of
view you have to you have to do the work
to figure out what it is you want to get
you have to you have to start not just
with don't start with what what angles
camera angles you want start with what
the scene is about
and
um
uh
yeah start there and then and I talk in
in this new book my dollhouse approach
to
figuring out your blocking to uh to get
some Dollhouse dolls or action figures
or Lego figures and uh and put some
furniture around on a tabletop and and
move them around and see where they see
where they want to move
when you're while you're seeing the
lines or where they want to stay stay in
one place and then figure out your your
shot list from from taking uh from from
looking at that through a viewfinder
and um but but that those places where
but but to have an idea before you start
moving them around of what the scene is
about what what happens to these
relationships how do people hurt each
other how do they help you rescue each
other how do they how does a love how
does how do they take one more step in a
love story or one more step in a breakup
and
and that that's where you always have to
start
and uh and and it will get easier to
figure out your shot list if you start
there if you start with I have to come
up with a shot list well like should I
do this shot should I you won't have a
reason for choosing any particular shot
so you need to know what this what the
scene is about in order to have a reason
for choosing the shots
so even even setting up a mock set with
a Lego figures or whatever even if it's
two stationary figures having a
discussion whether it's positive or
negative just all right well see this is
me and that's why this is a suggestion
I'm not saying everybody should do this
or has to do this but for me I uh uh
it does help if I take my two Lego
figures and I just sit them down here
and I say the lines out loud while
they're right here and I and I feel it
in my fingers no this person doesn't
want to move over here this person
doesn't want to move over here they're
they're I don't know it it it it you
have to try it to see if it works for
you I mean I'm not saying it would work
for everybody but but but it uh
it's you know how some people say that
they prefer when they're writing they
prefer to write long hand because it's
more physical than their their fingers
are more connected to their brain that
way
it's actually the opposite for me I find
my fingers more connected to my brain if
I'm using a keyboard but uh but anyway
but whatever connects your body to
itself to your your body to your brain
is always going to be is always going to
be a good thing uh
so so so I think that that that that
that that that helps clues in a
screenplay sort of underlying world of
behavior
can you talk the clues well that's a
script analysis you're looking for Clues
if you know if a character says uh uh I
remember you were the you know you were
the worst uh
you were the worst drunk in the dorm
well that's a clue they went to college
together
right that's a very simple clue and
um uh yeah you're looking for Clues like
that so that everything doesn't have to
be spelled out
what are the best ways for directors and
actors to unpack a screenplay
they're gonna they do that work
separately
usually
usually they would do that work
separately now there are exceptions of
course I have seen tape heard about and
seen tape of a rehearsal for the Social
Network directed by David Fincher where
they all sat in a room all the actors
and they uh and the director and the
writer I think was also in the room
Aaron sirkin and and they went through
the whole script line by line and talked
about what each line meant
so that would be if that can be done and
that would be unusual
but
movie came out very good so uh that's
very interesting to note that and and um
and and I think directors and actors can
do this this can even be done on Zoom
one one at a time that uh you know a
director and a lead actor can go over
all the line all the lines of their
scenes all of their scenes and allow
themselves the idea of talking about
what each line means is that you're
allowing questions you're you're even
starting with the question what does
this line mean with the understanding
that it might not mean what it literally
says it means and and just asking that
question what does this line mean
is you're on the way to acknowledging
that it has subtext
and I'm wondering who determines what
the line means is that the writer
director because the actor could embody
this character and it turns out they
actually may know some of the motivation
in some ways better
you're so right so it's very that's why
it's good to ask questions though you
know I one thing that I say to directors
is you will be they're afraid of being
judged by actors sometimes and I say you
will be judged by the quality of your
questions more than by uh the the
exactitude of your answers
so a good question is better than a
[ __ ] answer
but you got to have good questions so
that's the so that's the reason for
doing script analysis is so you'll have
good questions
and and then you know but if you're
using questions with actors which I
recommend that you uh Direct by acting
by asking questions you have to be
prepared for the director for the actor
to answer with something that you're not
expecting
so this is similar to a table read
uh
I like to call it a company read rather
than a table read because I like to do
them without tables but but uh yeah but
table read is the usual uh description
well this table read that they did with
you know the whole company and or maybe
just the main characters the main
characters and for the Social Network
that that was around a table and
um but but what I liked about it was
just this idea that for every line you
could say let's talk about it and it's
it assumes there could be some something
more to it than just the literal uh
words so say the literal words are I'm
uh I'm tired of talking about this okay
so that could be the literal line I'm
tired of talking about this then
if you say well what does this line mean
then you're you're opening the idea that
it it could mean
I actually think you're tired of talking
about this and I'm going to let you off
the hook I mean the obvious thing is I'm
tired of talking about this just shut up
right that's the obvious meaning but it
might mean something else even opposite
like I I I see your eyes uh wandering
and maybe we should go on to something
else
so so or it could be uh uh or it could
be I'm afraid this is going to get into
Dangerous Waters and uh
and there are things about me that I
don't want you to know
so let's stop talking
so it could mean it's opening the door
to to choices
to choices and as far as making the
choices here's here's something so
important
is that there are certain choices that
the actor and director must agree on
you know in order to be on the same page
about the story they're telling but
there are so many choices that they
don't have to be on the same page about
that that where the choices can be left
up to the actor
that the actor can have secrets
the actors can have secrets they can
have secrets from their other actors
and they can have secrets even from the
director
yeah this is uh this is really important
and now the director is responsible for
saying the scene Works let's move on to
the next one or saying no I'm still not
satisfied I want to work on it some more
oh but
they're they don't have to say make this
choice
because and and the and the thing is
that they don't know
when you have an idea it's an idea if a
director has an idea for a choice that
they think that the objective to
humiliate the other person is going to
work for the scene that's an idea it it
doesn't it's it's not the scene until
the actor tries it and it works
so yeah and when a director gives an
actor a secret
that none of the other cast will know
when is that happening is it a little
note are they pulling him aside having a
little chat it seems any anytime anytime
it can happen anytime yeah yeah the
director can suggest a secret
but but again I would always do that
with the language of permission to say I
was I was wondering if maybe they uh
did talk about this one time before and
it's just that the other your character
you're talking to doesn't remember
that could be a secret
it can be it's a very simple one or it
could be very big uh Secret
but uh yeah it could happen anytime
and that's a that's a big part of a
director's Talent is is being able to
have a you know their intuition their
leadership skills is being able to have
a sense of you know when when to step
when to step in when to step back
knowing when to step in when to step
back now that's something that I uh
I can't tell people you know they have
to get it by experience
they have to practice and practice and
do and try things over and over and and
uh
and then then develop an intuition about
when to step in when to step back when
to leave an actor alone and let them
figure it out themselves
went to
when to step in and say are you
struggling can I help
I had an idea it might be worth trying